thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a
compassionate wild ride with Stevo this
week we're talking to Shane Dawson who
clearly has made some serious mistakes
and while we were on the way to meet
Shane Dawson we watched a video about
all of the mistakes he's made and a lot
of it was news To Us by the time we got
to him we thought wow uh we wonder if
this is even a good idea but we decided
to press forward with an open mind and a
heart of compassion and I gotta say that
we are glad we did that
um it is what it is and it is certainly
extremely interesting and I dare say
extremely compassionate so with that
said let's get into it
you remember ready
yes sir right
ladies and gentlemen Shane Dawson
yeah dude
so we met once before when we did your
podcast for full screen and that was a
long time ago huh that was how many
cancellations ago was that I think that
was
four four and a half there was a half
there
man that was yeah we watched a video
that that kind of chronicled all of the
cancellations oh my God are we gonna
show up on some sort of list having you
on
whatever was interesting was that like
it was uh
you know they said that in in some cases
people will like uh you know
build careers become famous and then do
something like super offensive to people
but in this case of Shane Dawson he uh
that is not what happened that that like
Shane Dawson was super offensive the
whole time was actually like what he
became famous for kind of so then it's
like
uh it's just an interesting Dynamic
where uh you know you were just a wild
outrageously offensive guy and
everything was great until
people just got upset about it after the
fact
uh yeah
um yeah no it was
it was a lot I mean listen like I
I'm not one of those people that's mad
that I got canceled I mean maybe in the
beginning I was you know yeah because I
those videos were from a long time ago
and a lot of this stuff was from a long
time ago and I hadn't done anything like
that in years but I mean I'm also kind
of glad it all happened because
it made me face a lot of things and
realized uh yeah
a lot of things right
um so uh what has been um what's been
going on recently I thought you remember
maybe when when we got together like all
those years ago I uh I think I called up
my niece on the phone or or maybe we
made a video and sent it to my niece but
my niece was just such a rabid Shane
Dawson fan and I texted her yesterday I
said I said are you still like a fan of
Shane Dawson she's yeah like uh I said
oh because we're gonna record a podcast
with them tomorrow and she goes WTF oh
my God that's great and uh she said from
what I gather she's doing very well
since uh he got in trouble with the
popular media
her take on it seems to be that
that uh that you're they get the your
cancellation so to speak was with like
the mainstream media and that you know
under you know and and kind of your
world not sort of under that radar that
everything's cool
yeah I mean I
I think it was like when I started doing
YouTube
the people that were watching were you
know
I think the the types of people that
were watching my stuff changed in like
2018 2019 and I started doing things
about makeup and I think it opened up to
and not to make excuses but I think I
started doing YouTube videos for kind of
like [__] up weird Outcast people and
then the more mainstream YouTube got and
the more I was doing documentaries on
like work documentaries people don't
like me when I call them that but I was
doing videos about people that were more
mainstream so it was a lot of like yeah
and then they were really surprised by
all the old videos obviously
so yeah I mean sorry I'm so I don't talk
about this stuff really except for like
therapy so I don't know I don't know how
to like not go into like that mode yeah
that's cool we're on therapy yeah
we're we're big fans of therapy I got a
five o'clock today
um
so they helped me understand the uh the
the makeup it seems to me like kind of
counter-intuitive that that uh like do
you wear makeup regularly
so well I did a I did a series on um a
YouTuber who I was really fascinated by
who I'm friends with but at the time I
wasn't really friends with them uh
Jeffree Star who's like you might he's
been around forever in Myspace days so
he had this big makeup business I didn't
understand at all and I did a kind of a
series with him on my channel we were
talking about it and then he was like
well why don't you do a collaboration
with me with makeup I'm like well I
don't know anything about it but I'm one
of those people I don't know if it's OCD
or what it is but when I have a new
thing that I like want to do or whatever
I get obsessed with it so I jumped in I
bought a bunch of [__] makeup I
learned how to do it I got obsessed with
it and you say learned how to do it like
uh like how to put it on yeah like I
watched every [__] makeup tutorial
video in history I just watched all of
them and then um it was I mean but also
like I don't go out in the world and
wear makeup so yeah why do you want to
do a makeup like YouTube If like you
weren't wearing makeup or doing makeup
before that like what what made you want
to do the makeup well I want to do the
series because it was like a world I
didn't understand it was you know my
friend who's making hundreds of millions
of dollars doing this makeup stuff and I
had never seen any of it so to be able
to be a part of that and be in that was
I mean crazy but also I'm crazy I just
get so obsessed with things
um to a point where it's probably
unhealthy so I just got obsessed with it
it makes sense to me jeopardy star like
is known for wearing makeup I didn't
wear makeup all the time
um wasn't there some like crazy when you
say like how many cancellations go
wasn't there something around the makeup
with the Jeffree Star the there was like
a big issue I don't remember I feel like
they're you're asking me or everybody at
all yeah what was that I remember I
remember that wasn't there something
about like a warehouse being robbed or
something was that it oh yeah I mean
that's the thing with Jeffrey which is
why he's such a amazing person to film
like it's always something and that at
that time that year 2019
I would say is like the best year ever
but also was the worst year ever because
every day it was like
shit's going down yeah that day it was
Oh no I got canceled for something and
then that same day
I was supposed to propose to my then
boyfriend and then Jeffrey called me and
he's like my warehouse has been robbed
and he had all these videos and pictures
of these [__] guys scaling the walls
and like dropping in through the ceiling
and yeah just robbing all this makeup
which at the time I didn't understand
now I get it but that makeup was worth
so much money because it wasn't released
yet so it was kind of like getting
leaked to other makeup companies so they
could rip it off I don't know it's kind
of confusing yeah and he Jeffrey lives
in Wyoming right yeah he yeah he had all
of his businesses are in Wyoming too
I think so I know he moved a lot of
stuff out there yeah it's crazy how much
money there is in makeup
it's a lot of money but it's also like
it's scary it's like it's like yeah just
things I've just the actual I mean it's
I guess it's like Hollywood not that
I've been I mean you've been at
Hollywood you get it it's like
it's just so Cutthroat and crazy and
everything changes so fast and if you're
not trending anymore if you're not this
anymore and then the up and the down and
the enemies and it's like a like the mob
like it was in one sense the makeup
world or like uh the Youtube world
I think the YouTube world I mean the
YouTube world's like dramatic I guess I
mean but it's it's more low stakes like
with the makeup world it's yeah it's
people that
there was just always something going on
with these big companies because like
yeah they're making so much money
it was yeah it was a lot I'm happy that
I'm I mean I love Jeffrey so much I'm
happy I'm less around
all the
business stuff yeah he said that with um
you know trending and not turning it's
crazy to have a a career in YouTube for
15 years
yeah I mean that's like uh YouTube is
some by definition just fickle you know
like there's always something new and
like it's pretty impressive that uh that
you've endured for as long as you have
yeah yeah
no I think about that a lot I mean I'm
really grateful like
it's been a um it's been interesting
I mean yeah I started YouTube when that
it wasn't like a job or anything people
weren't making money from it and I just
was posting these weird videos like with
my grandma and stuff
um
but I've always wanted to make stuff I
just didn't know YouTuber I mean it
wasn't a thing so I don't know if I'm
making any sense I don't know how to do
this it makes perfect sense didn't you
have a podcast yeah but here's okay
here's the problem is I haven't like
I used to have a podcast where I would
interview people yeah and then I stopped
doing that I did that for years and then
I have a podcast now where it's like me
my husband my brother our camera guy we
sent we just like talk about random
stuff and I kind of like lead the
conversation and set up the like little
segments
you deflect the conversation away from
all your [__] yeah because I'm
you know haven't you talked about this
stuff before though or just not publicly
I don't think I've talked about it like
yeah not really like I'll touch on
things in in podcasts a little bit but
then I kind of stop because I I don't
wanna it's hard it's hard to talk about
stuff because if you talk about it
people think you're trying to be a
victim if you if you say about certain
things they think you're manipulating or
you're trying to change the narrative or
all this [__] so I just don't talk about
anything I mean the fact that you're
nervous about it is pretty authentic I
think and like it's better than having
like you know being a prepared because
you could tell when you start to talk
about it you stop talking about it which
means like there's shame around it and
like the neurons are just looping back
to the same
spot and I think talking about it helps
kind of connect new like neural Pathways
to where you're not like so you know
flight or fright uh with it and it just
gets easier and easier if you're not
comfortable talking about anything you
know we don't have to talk about
anything at all I think there's
something to what you said too that uh
you know when you say the fact the chain
is nervous about it there's something
authentic about that you know like uh if
you're if you're really comfortable like
oh yeah let's let's talk about you know
like that no problem there then um it
feels like you know there's no gravity
to it and you know like uh yeah there's
certainly trauma around it because like
I I can when you're breathing out like
that like I'll do that in therapy and
like my therapist is like dude
your brain doesn't know the difference
between like you know you running your
rep because like when that kind of stuff
happens like you're operating off your
Reptilian Brain and so it's like your
body doesn't know the difference whether
you're running from a dinosaur or like
somebody's just asking you a question
because like it hasn't been processed
so I mean I think it's good to to talk
about it and I mean I think the worst
has already happened
right and nobody's going to find out
anything you haven't lied about anything
so like you know saying [__] I think is
okay but I think the fact that you are
nervous about it is a good thing because
it's authentic
well thank you I mean that exactly what
you said sorry I've like cottonmouth
exactly what you said
is what my therapist said too which is
like
yeah I got into a place where
I was in fight or flight mode 24 hours a
day
or like
I mean not not as much anymore I don't
want to seem like I'm like [__]
like I'm just showing up to do a podcast
like that's not yours that's good
but you know like the last two years
after I got canceled and I was like I'm
done not making any videos ever again
I'm done I went through you know not to
get to you know whatever but it was
really bad and then we moved we moved to
Colorado that's where my husband's
family is and I'm really close to them
and I just wanted to get away for a bit
and also we found this house out there
that was unexpected so we moved out
there
and I had the best year of my whole life
like 2020 was really bad and 2021 was
like
I wasn't on my phone I wasn't on the
internet
um anyway yeah it was the best year ever
and then
and then around the end of 2021 I
started thinking like I wanna I do want
to make stuff again and
and like you said it's like
I'm obviously ashamed of a lot of the
old videos and the old sketches and
stuff but like you said I didn't
it's not like a secret thing I didn't
hurt anyone I mean I guess I heard
feelings but I didn't physically hurt
anyone I didn't rape anyone I didn't
like I didn't do anything to where I
should be in hiding
it took me a long time to get to that
place
to to believe that but
you know that I shouldn't be in hiding
or something but but when we were coming
out here and you're like okay I'm doing
a podcast where were you like oh [__] I
don't want them to ask me this oh I mean
what was the shame or fear there about
doing a podcast like because I know
there's maybe something specific that
you thought about that you didn't want
to go near
I mean it sounds
whatever but I
my biggest fear and why I say no to a
lot of stuff like this and I thought I'd
be getting asked a lot but I say no a
lot because I know the reaction is going
to be possibly negative for you guys so
for me I'm like okay
I love you I'm so grateful that you came
on my show all those years ago like that
was [__] insane like I still have
people asking me about that like my
brother's obsessed with you so
I wanted to say yes but I know you're
gonna get [__] and you're gonna get
comments people are gonna be like can't
believe you had him on and all this
stuff and then I'm not gonna read it but
I don't want that to like [__] up your
[__] and I don't want
you to regret it and yeah so it's like a
lot of like feeling like kind of the way
I put it is I feel like I'm cancer in a
way where I'm like this thing where if
people are around me now people they can
get canceled or and that's probably
ended that was more probably a couple
years ago but it does feel like that you
know like oh I'm I'm this [__] up
thing and if you're near me everybody's
mad at you now so I just kind of seclude
well that's sad
that's that's thoughtful and and uh you
know we appreciate that I think that our
whole kind of vibe is it is what it is
you know I think um that that the idea
of uh there being negative comments
there's gonna be negative comments no
matter what you do
um and I I'm personally kind of
interested in uh just the story of you
know
what happens after all that right you
know like um I think uh that a lot of
people in the world would take the
position that cancel culture went too
far and that it's you know
enough and and I think that having
really really taken the brunt of it and
uh you know showing up to to speak up
for yourself after the fact that there's
some courage in them and um anybody who
wants to you know kick you while you're
down and and you know pile on to a bunch
of traumatic stuff like um maybe maybe
what we're doing here is uh an exercise
in
shining a light on that and uh and and
showing it to be unnecessary
yeah I mean thank you for
um
sorry I don't
I promise I'm not like this all the time
no that's okay I mean just honestly it's
it's it's it's better that you're not
like you know
right Cavalier [__] I know hey guys
like I mean this is like what like you
know right I mean I think I I have
gotten past it like I I mean I weirdly
enough so I I hadn't done therapy in a
few years and I started back up again
right at the beginning of covid and I
told the therapist I was like you know I
was trying to explain to her my job and
explain to her like my issues and my
triggers because at that time every day
my my routine would be I would get up I
would go on Twitter and I would pray to
God that I wasn't trending for something
bad because it was happening a lot my
whole career so you know and if I wasn't
trending it was a good day but then
every like five hours I would have to
check and sometimes it would be there
and it would be like oh it's an old joke
from a video and then I would go through
this whole thing where it's like
I can't explain it but it feels like
your stomach is [__] eating itself
and you feel like you're dying and you
fight or flight and all that [__] it's
called anxiety yes yeah exactly so I
would go through that a lot and I was
trying to explain it to her and then
literally like two months later I got
canceled and I would say it was a bad
like it was
it was probably the worst cancel
situation I've seen and it was so
intense
and it like [__] up my family and like
my friends and I love it was really bad
and but luckily I was in therapy so she
was guiding me through the whole thing
and um now it's been like two and a half
years and I'm so good so I don't want
you to think I'm like is it
true that at the point when when it
really kind of took a left turn that
your videos were getting like 40 million
views per video
what can I say numbers matter and if you
can put together an audience online of
any size then you're out of your mind if
you're not selling products to that
audience like me I sell Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and I sell it
pretty well how with shipstation why
because ship station takes all of the
different platforms you can sell on
Amazon
Etsy your own website whatever it is
brings them all into one easy to use
interface and gives you the best
shipping rates which are normally
reserved for Fortune 500 companies
that's because into that interface they
bring all of the different shippers
United States Post Office UPS FedEx and
they give you the best rates when you
get an order online boom we just have
our label print out we put it in the Box
slap on the label and it's out the door
it saves money it makes everything
unbelievably easy and like I said we
sell this hot sauce on Amazon we sell it
at stevo.com and without ship station we
couldn't sell any of it telling you this
stuff makes us money because of ship
station and if you go to
shipstation.com and use the promo code
Stevo you're going to find out exactly
what I'm talking about and not even pay
anything for 60 days that's a two-month
free trial with all of the bells and
whistles the chip station provides and
it's totally risk-free so one more time
go to ships
station.com and use the promo code Stevo
and makeshift happen yeah dude let's get
back to it
which isn't good like listen I'm so
grateful for that and like that's
awesome but I was never enjoying it like
and I know that sounds like I'm
bullshitting but I really wasn't because
I don't know what the videos or the
amount of views the views or like the
because
the annoying money
I mean listen you would think my cpms on
YouTube have always been [__] [__]
so but either way whatever I'm grateful
for it but but no I wasn't enjoying it
because it was always what's next how
what do I do what if the next one
doesn't do well and I would freak out
about it I'd be like well that's not
good enough and I would film all these
videos and never post them because I'm
just like well it's not going to get 40
million views people are going to think
it sucks how do what do I do what do I
do and it was getting so bad to where my
relationship was [__] up I like my
eating issues were [__] up I was just
in the worst headspace but I was getting
all these views so it was the weirdest
like
you know and then I got canceled thank
God because I figured my [__] out and
you know I seem to recall that you know
when we got together for your podcast
years ago that you had like a crazy
upload schedule that you would put up
like three videos every week
yeah and I remember just thinking how do
you come up with that much content you
know and and I think the answer was that
you would have regular creative meetings
to just determine what other videos
going to be and then you just make them
I wish no uh that's a good idea I I've
tried to find people in the past that I
could
do that with like come up with you know
things like that but no that was mostly
just like
back when I was doing five videos a week
that was when I was just like okay kind
of on autopilot like okay these are the
things I enjoy doing I'm just gonna make
videos about them I'm gonna shoot them
all in a day I'm gonna you know lose my
mind over that that was a bad
time period for me just because I really
was not enjoying it like at all like I
was like okay I have to keep going
because if I stop people are mad at me
because they're like why aren't you
posting today what happened to the video
so I was just on autopilot doing it and
then I got into a pretty serious
relationship and I started posting less
and I started like
um you know when um
like when all the the kind of Worlds
crumbling around you and you know you're
going from 40 million views on a video
and then all of a sudden now you're not
posting or even before that were you
thinking about like just taking the the
money that you had earned in your career
and putting it to work for you in in
other ways so that you don't have to be
in the spotlight anymore
yeah I mean I never had I don't have
like this is such a weird thing to talk
about but I don't want people to think
I'm I don't know whatever it doesn't
matter I I don't have as much money as I
think people think I do because the
makeup thing people thought I made like
20 million dollars and I did not and um
I've never killed it on YouTube like
financially just because my videos
have been controversial so it's not like
I had enough money where I could just
retire or something so but I did know I
was like okay
around the lap right before I got
canceled I was really depressed I didn't
know what I was going to make it next I
felt uninspired I felt like okay I
already did everything on YouTube I
wanted to do I want to make a movie but
nobody's giving me the money to make a
movie so I was gonna fund my own movie
which would have cleaned me out but I
was like you know but it's gonna be
worth it because I'm crazy I'm like it's
gonna be worth it and blah blah and then
I got canceled and I didn't do it thank
God that would have been the stupidest
decision in the world but
um
so yeah uh sorry for your question it
was just like uh you know
kind of I I've
viewed it as a way of getting out of the
attention [__] business yes you know
like I'd like I'm an attention [__] and
like for me the Ultimate Dream the
ultimate goal is to to have an out if
it's some like uh some business
thing that I can get going like you can
see yourself in a situation where you're
out out of the camera's eye
um I mean like I was I was like no never
I was I'd like to get in front of a
camera because it's my choice too okay
not because like you know for me the
most upsetting like traumatizing
depressing stuff is uh documentaries
slash biopics about like ha like
Hollywood personalities movie stars
entertainers who uh like in the final
stages of their life were dead broke and
like doing everything they could to milk
their their their former self and their
form you know like yeah just like Mike
Tyson did hangover too just to feel his
cocaine habit because he didn't have any
more money that could be wrong but like
he was like dude these guys were like
what the [__] is this guy doing on here
he's like I just had to get some money
for my cocaine I can't imagine it got
that much money for that but like people
had that come to mind there's a there's
a movie called Stan and Ollie and it's
the story of uh Laurel and Hardy and
here these guys were in their like 60s
and 70s like going on tour like beating
themselves up doing all this slapsticks
dude that Judy Garland perfect example
um Buster Keaton you know Buster
Keaton's the biggest Legend ever the
most iconic like old school Hollywood
guy and in his late years he was just
down and out and like I don't I I don't
wanna be like dead broke in the like the
later stages of my life I don't want to
be having to beat myself up like uh for
money I don't want to just be in that
undignified situation so I'm always
trying to think about a way to get out
do you have an end number in mind where
you can retire you don't have to say it
but like is there a number I I do not no
well let's start there and we can work
backwards
she had a goal yeah so she she's like
one of my favorite talk show hosts when
I was little and she had her talk show
and it only went for like four or five
years and she canceled it and they were
like why you were making all this money
and she's like I hit 100 million in my
bank account and I was like [__] it I'm
out yeah and she's been out since I mean
she went back for a few things but yeah
like 100 million in her mind was like
the number and I was like damn
that is so crazy it's so crazy to think
about that much money but also to think
about like
it was only four years she could have
kept going for another 15 years and she
would have a billion dollars but she
didn't care like yeah
yeah
you're gonna hate me for doing this but
I'm gonna go deep okay
um you brought up the fact that like you
didn't want to come on people's podcasts
because you felt like a cancer
but did you always feel like a cancer
like was that that that's not the first
time that you felt coming on because I
the reason I say that is because you
know you see you
your whole idea of like making videos
would be for shock value right and and I
would think that like
to have that kind of a thought system
you kind of had like a lot of resentment
in you before you started making videos
and you found out like that you know you
can make videos and then you became
shocking and and maybe in your head you
were like like [__] it I like [__]
everybody I feel like a cancer anyway in
life so like I'm just gonna go like you
felt justified by going that hard
is that some level of accuracy to it
yeah I mean I think
oh
it sounds weird but I am not like as a
human as a person I'm not
like a gross person I'm not like a
shocking person in my real life I'm not
making crazy gross jokes I'm not I've
never been that I've always been really
quiet so with the videos I mean I grew
up
watching you know scary movie and uh you
know Chappelle and all those things so
that was kind of how my
what I liked formed and I love playing
characters and wearing wigs and doing
all these things and I do love getting a
reaction like I would make these videos
and I would show my mom who's like
really religious Christian
and my favorite part of making the
videos would be watching my mom's
reactions because it was so like I love
when people scream because they are
laughing or they scream because they're
shocked it's just like oh my God and so
I was doing that and I did it in high
school like I would do these video
projects in high school and the teachers
would freak out because they were like I
can't believe he did this like what the
[__] and that was kind of you know the
beginning of that so yeah but it was
weird because then in when I'm not in
these videos I'm not that bad at all
so that was kind of weird because people
thought oh why go that route
in your videos like shock value like I
think because I just love it doing
things because you love them makes all
the sense in the world like the way I am
with Lux you know I do her because I
love her and I love using Bluetooth
tablets because they just make it more
fun now when you think of a of a tablet
that has the same active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis there is maybe a
thought of like wow like do I need that
and you know the way I answer that is is
it gonna make my life more fun and the
answer is yes
it does Bluetooth makes my relationship
with my girl more fun and if there's a
chance that it could make your relations
more fun then why wouldn't you be
open-minded to that and if you are
open-minded to that then why wouldn't
you get an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets completely for free
and only pay five dollars for shipping I
mean it's a pretty simple stuff to me
and if you go to bluetooth.com and use
the promo code Stevo take a couple
minutes to consult with the medical
provider online get your prescription
locked in and again that's an entire
month's supply of Bluetooth tablets
completely for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping so let's ask that
question one more time might this make
My Relations more fun and I'm telling
you the answer is yes so go to
bluetooth.com and use the promo code
Stevo yeah dude let's get back to it
people were really liking the videos and
I was you know being asked to go to
YouTube things and I had YouTube friends
and and but there were a few people that
were mad and were calling it out and I
was you know being like no well people
think it's funny and I'm not trying to
be offensive so it's fine which is
stupid I should have listened to those
people but
um but yeah it wasn't like I never
wanted to be that right like I never
want to be the person that's making all
this horrible [__] like that was not
what I wanted to do like I wanted to
like all even some of these videos that
were so offensive that when you look
back they're like the most offensive
ones I the moral of the video would be
about suicide or you know anti-bullying
or would be about eating disorders or
something I dealt with and I would wrap
that into the video so which doesn't
make sense when you watch it it's like
why is he doing all this horrible [__]
but then at the end he's trying to do
something meaningful and I don't know I
honestly don't know why I was doing that
like I
do you ever have any cool stories of
like people you're actually like helping
people out with the mental health and
them like calling and getting saved and
all that oh yeah I mean I think I
because I was so open about my issues
from when I started you know doing stuff
on the internet
and because I've done so many videos
about suicide about
um cutting or eating disorder because
I've done so much of that over the years
I think a lot of people did
um
get something out of that I've talked to
a lot of people that have and
you know but yeah I don't I don't
know what what
why what is like cutting like uh why do
people cut is it because they don't feel
they feel dead inside and they want to
like feel alive is that the action of
The Cutting because I know that's
something yeah I mean I think it's
different for everyone I think it's kind
of like um so I I never cut but I was
this is kind of gross to talk about but
I was I had a lot of things I did but
one of them was I would like pick my
skin yeah which is stupid you should not
do that but I kind of still do it a
little bit and I do it because I'm
anxious or thinking about something or
kind of and it's just something I I do
when I'm working through something or
not dealing with something and I think
cutting for some people is kind of like
well I don't want to think about all
these things and I don't want to
whatever so I'm gonna put all my pain
into one place and I can only focus on
the pain I feel like it's the same with
like drugs and alcohol yeah you know
having to just numb what you're going
through you know you don't do drugs or
alcohol no I I used to like drinking but
now I can't my stomach hurts every time
really so now I can't I mean my issues
are like yeah food yeah yeah me too
right yeah I'm not and I'm not picking
on it I'm just fascinated you know with
with different like patterns and and
certain things and I've always been
interested in that
um I knew a pretty girl
who picked her skin a lot and when she
told me that it
I'm like oh yeah that's why she always
wears long sleeves you know and it's
like
I don't know just I found it fascinating
but yeah it's all the same facet of
covering up something at the root cause
yeah Jeff so not to keep bringing him up
but Jeffrey uh he one of the first
things I found out about him when I was
doing that series on him was he's full
body tattoos right like full body like
that's his thing and then he showed me
and he was explaining that he started
getting tattoos to cover up his cut
scars and I was like what and then I
looked closer and his entire like body
is covered in scars I was just like whoa
like so yeah I've talked to him about it
he's kind of explained so my my you know
knowledge on cutting and why people do
and stuff is kind of based on what he's
told me but
um but yeah people I don't know
everybody has their thing and you know
yeah life sucks a lot but no it's also
great it's also great yeah
yeah man the uh I saw a video on my
YouTube feed the other day it said why
is like why you should stop worrying or
something like this will make you stop
worrying
okay that's interesting I clicked on it
and it said like
you know
hundreds of billions of years ago there
was nothing and you know like it was
just kind of putting into perspective
like how am I nude and you know like
we're on a speck of dust and you know
like and uh after watching it I really
did feel a lot more calm and and that it
quelled my worrying and I thought you
know what she's watching stuff like this
all the time like uh let me get to
populate my feed with videos about why
like ain't no thing yeah
they asked if you when you think do you
think in the future or the past
ah probably I'm more of a future future
so if you think in the future you're
more anxious you could think of the past
you're more depressed
whoa 100 but the right answer is if you
ask like somebody like you know do you
think in the past of the future and you
just say I think in the present do you
believe them I don't believe those
people what do you think about you think
about the past are you depressed yes
you're right
that's so crazy I never thought about
that and if you think in the future
you're kind of just future tripping
you're nervous you're anxious I'm
anxious too I'm 100 future Tripper yeah
so of course me too I mean I think the
right but everybody's like you know just
thinking the presence and mindfulness
but nobody does that I mean it's hard to
you know that's why they have the rubber
bands where they snap out or yeah I
don't know maybe they cut because they
want to live in the present but uh yeah
it's just I mean mental health is a
whole other [__] beast I read this
book
um
uh back in 2001 it was called like the
Feeling Good Handbook by Dr
some [__] doctor but it was the
number one book recommended to people in
between therapy and like he would just
go into these people's lives like this
one lady would wash your hands a
thousand times a day because she thought
the dirt on her hands would give her
kids leukemia so she was just constantly
washing her hands and he would just he
had thousands and thousands of case
studies by this where he would read you
off the transcripts in the therapy and
he'd be like okay well why do you think
that the dirt on your hands are going to
give your kids leukemia she's like well
because if I kill them like then I'll be
all alone he's like okay well what
happens if you're all alone and then he
just keeps breaking it down and breaking
it down and you know and then they go
well when I was you know when I was when
I was younger I was alone because my
parents divorced and he's like okay why
was that so bad and it's like well
because it was my fault that my parents
divorced and he's and so like once he
made her flip her script on like it
wasn't her fault that her parents
divorced she stopped washing her hands
so much but yeah like hundreds of cases
like this where he would just go through
and it's all just a stem of [__]
whatever you know
wow yeah it sucks to squander the
moments that that could be wonderful
with worry about things that have not
even happened in 99 of them never do
you know it's so true for sure yeah I
mean I think in the final analysis my
life will have been squandered over
worry about you know just gonna keep
playing that video
I know and I look at like our work
schedule you know we've just been gone
in Australia and New Zealand for a month
and a week and it was like
a pretty miserable existence you know if
I got there like 10 days before you guys
so I was just [__] deep in the cut it
was gnarly and and you know and I just
have this default setting where it's
like everything is not going to be okay
I have to work I have to work I have to
work like to try to make it so that
everything's gonna be okay because it's
not gonna be okay I gotta I gotta earn I
gotta earn and like my quality of life
like is not important what's important
is later trying to make it so
everything's gonna be okay and I'm
throwing my present quality of life out
the window to try to secure okayness in
the future and I'm still convinced that
everything's not gonna be okay yeah well
you don't you don't even have an end
number in mind that you're working
towards you're just digging with no
[__] how many how many how many feet
do you want to go down I don't know just
digging
off but did he just ask me how much
digging I want to do for retirement
seems silly because digging to me is
something that you do to get into debt
and to get into a bowl of my favorite
cereal from Magic spoon I'd dig into
that stuff like crazy because it's
delicious man it's like a guilty
pleasure that you're not guilty about at
all it's like when I ate cereal as a
little kid that awful sugary stuff that
was terrible for me and this stuff is
every bit as delicious but it's got like
13 to 14 grams of protein per serving
like net four to five grams of carbs per
serving which is negligible it's got
zero grams of sugar per serving I mean
hey if if you're looking at me these
days you're seeing that I am fitter and
thinner than I am at other times and I
attribute this to my avoiding sugar and
man am I successful with that with magic
spoon
magicspoon.com Stevo and to use the perm
occurred Stevo to get five dollars off
your order I'm telling you I love this
stuff I eat it all the time and I'm
looking and feeling better because of it
so one more time go to magicspoon.com
Stevo and use the promo code Stevo
you'll be glad you did now let's get
back to it
it'd probably become a little bit easier
to like you know more palpatible if you
have a number in mind then you're like
okay let's start there right work
backwards but but even if you hit that
number I feel like you would still well
that's the reason he gets a blue check
mark he's still gonna be [__] dead
will you tell him that a blue check mark
isn't that big of a deal on Instagram oh
you want a blue check yeah yeah I don't
know isn't it not real anymore yeah
um
the uh
sorry I just had a crazy brain fart what
would do you have any goals I mean what
do you what's going on like what do you
want to do out of life now or like any
New Perspective shift or like is there a
new Shane Dawson
like what do you what's change what do
you want to do with your life what do
you have any purpose yeah I mean my I
mean my real my life life I uh were
having a baby
only two or three so we uh
yeah we're doing that in
I mean she's the surrogate is being
implanted in a few weeks so
that's happening which I'm so excited
about
um how much legal red tape is there
before that because isn't it like a and
the prices well that okay that's the
darkest part is pressing purchase on a
mother like it's like you want a
surrogate well so that's the other thing
I didn't know so egg donors this might
be boring sorry guys egg donors is
different so like the egg donors who is
the mother and then they they put your
sperm in the egg and then they put it in
a surrogate who has no like connect
their genetic yeah put in there you or
your husband so we did both of our sperm
so you guys just do a double batch and
then you just mixed it together so you
can cook it all up and well that's the
other thing too because I'm like well
would I I mean I know what I look like
as a girl it's not great but I'm like
but do I want
never mind I was gonna say something
really dark but yes so it is oh you're
shooting progress here thank you well
I'm thinking about my future kid
watching this you know what I mean there
you go that changes everything like if I
would have known I was gonna have kids
one day that would have the internet
that everything stays there forever and
then they can go and be like Daddy what
is this I never would have done any of
it I mean I don't regret it I think
everything happens for a reason but
um so yes we're cooking them up
um what do you mean by cooking them up I
was going I was going along with his
mixing thing but you know like so yeah
they we have 12 potential children
I believe 12. six months of mine six of
his
um or do we have 24 sperm I remember yes
oh so you're saying there's there's uh
12 eggs yeah and they can keep an egg
viable like in a freezer well that's the
other thing so the embryos so the number
kind of keeps going down it's like oh we
got 30 whatever eggs okay only this many
survived okay only this many sperms
attached so now we're left with 12 six
boys six girls six of mine six of his
and their third embryos and they're
frozen so they're like two weeks old
each which I didn't know two week old
like human babies right well well yeah
and now I'm thinking like I gotta bring
them all because like there's just means
some frozen forever that are two weeks
old like they're alive in my head I
don't know maybe that's Han Solo so what
you want to have all 12 no I don't know
at the same time no well no [__]
Octomom
that's the new Shane no uh that's your
new show
um yeah no so I mean I think we want to
have three kids but now now that we have
12 I don't know what to do we should
start giving them to people I don't is
that that's bad I can't do that the
auction button on your website
yeah I don't know yeah I don't know so
so there's that I mean but as far as
like career stuff
um I've I just really want to make
um a horror movie that's kind of my I
have two scripts written and one of them
kind of fell through in the last couple
months
so now I'm kind of rerouting and trying
to get this one made but but yeah that's
kind of Michael but that's gonna I mean
I'm more like I'm not quite satisfied
yet with the the surrogate like that
like
and I'm just interested the the uh it's
very common I think that the a surrogate
mother will
you know after growing this baby inside
of them have some attachment and then
like uh you know get cold feet or
whatever I don't want to give up the
baby it's my baby
I wasn't aware of the baby inside them
not being genetically there so it's a
different wrinkle but presumably they
still have some kind of attachment and
there's all kinds of legal paperwork
like uh you know so
what's the legal process like in in uh
establishing the agreement with the
surrogate and what's the interpersonal
uh kind of did do you develop a
relationship with them before picking
them right
yeah it was wild we started like a year
and a half ago
actually no I think just a year ago and
um so first way to pick the egg donor
and we instantly both of us knew we
didn't tell each other but we knew the
donor and then I said it and he said it
and we're like oh my God that's the one
so we picked her
um why what about her
I don't know it was just like a weird
like God my sister first thing my sister
had a sperm donor she was artificially
inseminated the the my niece who's such
a fan of yours and um what struck me
about the process was that by the time
you make it through all the screening
they've they've determined that there is
no like uh like no medical problems to
worry about like going through the whole
family tree everybody in the family tree
is all uh healthy into their like 80s
like they're all like college educated
like there's just it's just crazy it's
almost like the Olympics of being an
impressive person that you have to like
you know by the time you become a donor
like you're just
kind of documented as being like just
the picture of health and and
accomplishment and so the the that is
pretty impressive well the thing with
sperm donors do because my therapist she
was we were talking about it and uh she
had used sperm donor in the past and she
was like you know what's crazy is like
you know when you're picking the sperm
donor there's like levels like Financial
levels like okay if you pay an extra
hundred dollars you can get a voice note
from them so you can hear their voice if
you pay another hundred they'll draw you
a picture I'm like this is supposed to
go funny it's like only thing yeah it's
crazy I'm like what the [__] is this so
it's bizarre I mean the whole the whole
process is extremely depressing and
amazing and it took a lot of like mental
gymnastics to figure out how to not get
depressed about it but after meeting
both of them
and really donor and the surrogate yeah
and getting you know
um
their stories and why they're doing this
because that was my fear I'm like well
what if they how could they have a baby
and not want to keep it how is that
possible Right but
the girl who's donating the eggs she was
born through egg donors because her
parents use them so that she had like a
connection to that she's done it once
before and her whole thing was she was
like you know I would love to be in some
kind of you know I'd like to be updated
or be you know to I don't want it to be
a thing where I give my eggs and I don't
know anything after that and I was like
great because I wanted to be able to
tell our kids sounds like entanglements
sounds like strings attached gotta deal
with this person
I wanted that though because I I want to
be able to tell my kids one day because
you know listen I'm realistic about it
too and some people get mad when I say
this and by some people I mean people in
my family but I'm like I want to be
honest with my kid I know they're going
to see a commercial where there's a
mommy and they're going to be like why
don't I have a mommy and they're going
to have some issues with that they're
gonna be sad about that and I want to be
able to explain it to them and also you
know when they're ready show them a
picture or you know I want I don't want
it to be this weird [__] up secret
that [__] them up that sounds like a
egg donor is way different president
sperm donor because in the case of the
sperm donor it's uh you can find out
their their whole family treats medical
history their whole family trees
education history like everything about
them but you cannot like legally you
cannot
um get their name or you know like it's
sort of a rite of passage for adopted
kids to go and track down their
biological parents you know like you
hear about it a lot and it's like a you
know it's a thing but in the case of of
uh someone who was artificially
inseminated with this donor sperm it is
0.0 there is no rite of passage for my
niece to go and find her biological
father because it is like legally
precluded you definitely cannot get a
picture of of the person well I also now
I'm thinking about it I really hope I I
don't want to offend anybody that you
know I don't want to seem like if you
don't know who your father is or your
mom yeah I'm sorry I didn't mean to say
it like
don't don't trip because I think that's
just natural you know a human
consideration right yeah I mean but it
is yeah I mean with the surrogate too so
she's done this before and um I I asked
her like how do you because she has kids
of her own I'm like how do you how do
you explain this to your kid that you
have other babies that they don't you
know whatever and so she had like a word
for it like suro's sister so like you
know she's very open with her daughter
and
um I just want it to be open I don't
want it to be weird or like secretive
just because I my childhood had a lot of
some secretive weird [__] and you know I
think that is in turn what made me you
know really delve into food and [__]
up a lot of things for me once again
everything happens for a reason so I'm
fine with it but you know I just wanna I
don't know I'm just trying to figure it
out what's your food of choice
well I mean nachos I guess I didn't have
to think anything Mexican food Mission
Burrito oh my God carbs yeah
I'm a sugar guy I'm a carbs guy really
sugar for me too I guess I'm both I mean
I like Mexican food but I also like yeah
I like desserts I mean that yeah I don't
know when I'll ever figure that out like
it's a hard one because you have to eat
you have to and because so I was like
400 pounds in high school and then I
lost like 200 pounds and when I was 18.
through very unhealthy ways
um and I kept it off for a long time but
then it's like when you [__] up your
metabolism that much you kind of have to
starve yourself to stay to stay thin and
that's when I started YouTube and then
you know
so I've just gone up and down and up and
down and now I don't weigh myself so I I
don't even know what I am anymore but I
thought I'd be done with this by now
your unhealthy ways were laxatives
no I mean because I I took a laxative
when I and I was talking to our buddy
bill and I was like dude like uh he he
asked me that question and he's like
he's like are you ever doing laxative I
was like yeah like you know once in a
while when I get back from a trip or
something's like dude be careful because
a lot of people [__] have laxative
addictions and I'm like that's a thing
he's like oh my God he's like dude he's
like I couldn't go anywhere without
[__] laxatives
every day because you can lose weight
you can eat whatever you want and [__]
it out yeah it's the same thing as like
uh being a uh
purging yeah yeah that's yeah that's
what I did that's a did that [__] up
your esophagus at all
so I had like two situations where I
where blood came out and I was like oh
my God because that's the biggest fear
with bulimia is that at any point your
esophagus can explode and you'll die
like that's wow you'll just have a heart
attack heart attack from throwing up it
makes you anemic is that right and then
the lack of iron in your blood will lead
to a heart attack yeah yeah yeah and
like add a young ass age you have issues
with that too right from throwing up or
I don't know what the cause of my
esophageal issues was acid reflux
barfing drugs like I mean I don't know
yeah
wow so hope nobody's eating
let me give me all the [__] issues
you never know right right we all look
different but we have the same issues oh
yeah especially like yeah the
yeah the food stuff is yeah I thought I
mean I'm almost 35 I was like how in my
head when I was little I was like oh by
the time I'm in my 30s I'm gonna be fine
like I'm not gonna have any problems and
and every year it does get a little
easier because I care a little less what
I look like but it still does come down
to like you know in my head I'm 400
pounds I feel even like to be honest I
was I would say 50 nervous about doing
this because I didn't want to be a bad
guest because I didn't want to be afraid
to answer stuff and be weird my other 50
was like oh I feel fat especially right
now I'm like oh I feel fat so I'm gonna
look fat like oh my God whatever so it's
like yeah it's still something that's
like
did I go through the same [__] every day
I'm [__] stoked it's cold outside
when he pulled up and I ran outside and
I was sweating and I had my jacket on
and I looked in here and I'm like oh it
could get hot in there and I'm wearing a
jacket but like there's no other [__]
option yeah you know somebody has body
dysmorphia when they're wearing hoodies
in the summer summer yeah it's like uh
in Australia I [__] did it it was
[__] 107. yeah and then you just have
to lie to people and be like no I'm I'm
like weird like this really you're
sweating I'm like oh am I don't judge me
you're just like this just showered
I find that um
I I'm feeling a great deal of compassion
for you and uh you know like I I see
like I can you're honest You're
vulnerable I can feel like the the the
trauma of like everything that's
happened with uh you know cancel culture
and I I kind of like
you know I
like I can just maybe it's like uh you
know empathy but I I can feel your your
pain and it makes me uh you know
it cultivates compassion you know I want
to like I want everything to be okay for
you
thank you that's the nicest thing ever I
mean sorry that I'm making you feel bad
no no I mean it's not like yeah like
that yeah it's gonna make me feel bad
but it's like I don't know like Scott
said You know here you've uh you know
like the the fact of you being nervous
it uh I mean I could see the uh
indicators of like picking your fingers
like you're uncomfortable talking about
this [__] clearly you're blowing out
you're like yeah but to Scott's Point
that's real that's vulnerable yeah to
Scott's Point there's like there you
know it's okay if you pick your feet I
know no I'm like oh [__] no I always
notice things like that with people
because I I mean I I'm the same way too
you know I remember uh at you know one
of our our sober functions talking to a
sober guy
and uh and and just expressing to him
that um
that like
I uh
I felt really just ashamed of what you
know what I had become like what I
turned into with drugs and alcohol and I
was and I was like yeah like it's
probably not good to be so like shameful
about it and and this guy said no dude
like a regret is absolutely healthy and
important and the way forward you know
and I think that when Scott points out
that that you're nervous about this that
you know that like that there's like it
takes me back to that that sober guy
telling me how uh how valuable regret is
you know if you don't like regret things
that uh then then you're never going to
learn from your mistakes unless you
properly regret them yeah and you don't
get humbled I mean I think back to like
how I was in high school and people like
talk about you know from like
16 to [__] 24 like I don't like to
think back about the person I was
because
I mean I was a [__]
[__]
anytime Scott starts a story with one
time when I was in high school you know
it it's going to be the most
outrageously entertaining story yeah I
mean but like I don't even like to
identify with that person anymore yeah
you know but you consider regret and
shame the same thing
um
no I'm shameful of a lot of most of my
past but I don't regret most of it ooh
other way around you you wanna you wanna
constructively regret things remember
mistakes and regret them constructively
so as to not repeat the behavior for
sure but
shame as I understand it is not
constructive that's like like you regret
an action you have Shame about a person
you know like you know like shame is
more you know I'm shameful of who I am
okay you know and what I am versus like
like separate separate the action from
the person gotcha yeah yeah and I
suppose it follows the you know you do
something you regret it but like but
people I think I think what Al what
addiction comes down to is
a shame addiction like you're addicted
to feeling the shame because you feel
like a piece of [__] yeah so you want to
identify with that shame
so you keep doing Shameless acts yeah
shameful yeah I I remember
uh
talking to somebody about like this this
uh little and inner dialogue this this
negotiation about whether or not I'm
gonna have a dessert after a meal it's
like I want to have it but I know that
I'm gonna
be ashamed of it I know that I'm like uh
you know as soon as I get done eating it
I'm gonna regret it I'm gonna feel
ashamed about it
and somebody suggested to me that it's
actually
more than the pleasure of eating the
dessert the actual reward is the shame
that you choose to eat the dessert
because you derive some kind of perverse
pleasure in the cycle of Shame yeah and
that you're actually like it's an
exercise in in the care is an
opportunity I'm going to give myself to
beat myself up because there's this
perverse it's a core belief like well
you believe yourself to be like well I'm
a piece of [__] yeah and the shame
matches up to that like value yeah I
think that's what the cutting is
motivated by too everything like I'm I'm
a bad person and I deserve to like I
deserve for bad things to happen to me
and so here I'm gonna cut myself
and that's kind of uh
uh you got I don't know what's going on
with his RV life
I turned out into the blue button on
it's on
I think if you turn down then the lights
are gonna go out yeah you feel good
about it you feel I mean like you feel
good that you've talked about all this
oh
I thought you meant about my eating
I was like well now I'm realizing the
shame part
um
but I mean is there anything that you
like was it as difficult I mean I feel
like you faced some [__] coming in here
and like you're on the other side of it
it wasn't so bad
yeah I mean I'm I'm grateful that I'm
comfortable
you know
with I don't think I I yeah because I
haven't really talked about this stuff
in this type of a way I try to like make
jokes about it or get out of it but
yeah I mean I'm happy to talk about
stuff I think it's hard because in my
real life I've moved past it and I'm
happy and things are good and like you
know way better than before I got
canceled as far as like my work life
balance and everything is good but yeah
it's weird like the second I start
talking about it I almost like go right
back into
that place I was in which shows that I
really am not past it because I can so
easily fall right back into that feeling
of like my life is over well they they
say one of the best things about like um
and I'm not like preaching 12-step but
they I was listening to a guy talk about
um one of the good things about like
having that at a group level is that
when everybody comes into those rooms
there's shame
and the practice of speaking out
publicly like whatever it is that you're
and
no nobody's judging you
rewires the neurons in your brain to
where you're it it becomes easier and
easier to talk about because when you
talk about it nobody's like saying [__]
and you're like oh it's not that bad and
that's like one of the benefits of like
speaking at a group level or even with
us like it's not as bad as you think it
is in your head
because you're only as sick as your
secrets
so
yeah there's a difference between being
in a safe environment with uh yeah
YouTube
aren't going to be done and then
subjecting yourself to like
Mass criticism on like uh yeah millions
of people
so
but there's certainly you know no no
judgment here you know thank you I mean
no I appreciate it and I want to get
better at like talking about stuff I
think and I've tried to do it on my
podcast but then I always just shut down
because
I don't
I don't know I don't wanna
it's just really complicated it's hard
to talk about cancel stuff cancel
culture when
like I'm not delusional I know why I got
canceled I I understand it I get it I
feel sorry about it
um but yeah it was a lot and it I don't
think any person should be put through
that because if I didn't have
Rylan I'd be dead like so I I want to at
some point talk about it more because I
feel I kind of talk about in therapy a
lot I'm like I want to do something for
people because
cancel culture isn't just on YouTube
it's everywhere it's in people like I've
had people that I know who have lost
jobs because of a patient who said
something that wasn't true and then this
and that it's like it's happening
everywhere and so many people feel like
it feel like this so it's like yeah at
some point I do want to get better
talking about it because I you know I I
am grateful that I
M okay
after all of that but it's hard to talk
about that because then people are like
oh you're trying to you know [__]
feel bad about or be a victim and this
and that so then I just say well [__] it
I'm just not going to talk about you
know yeah I think the worst thing that
you can do though is just to like um
make a joke yeah like uh make a joke
about it or you know at least because
then that's just uh it's a you know
deflection for sure and
um you know I think the more that you're
honest and vulnerable about it the it
always reminds me of this the the word
personality comes from the the root word
persona which means to wear a mask and I
always like the people that have the
best Personalities in the world just
makes me think of like
that they're covering up the most you
know so if somebody's like hey what's
like they're just two on and they're too
charismatic it's like that person's
really hurt inside
right so you don't I think want to
make a joke about anything you've ever
done because it's not funny and
everybody knows it's not funny so just
be real about it just like [__] dude
you're pretty honest and vulnerable with
us and that's a lot easier than being
like okay so anyway that is so [__]
true because at the beginning when I
started trying to get back into making
stuff again I was really making a lot of
jokes about suicide like too much
borderline like why was I doing that
um and
I in the moment I I try not to do this
but I watched like a video of somebody
reacting to the video because it was my
first one back and you know since I had
been canceled and one of the suicide
jokes came up and the person was just
like um
and I was like oh I just felt so
embarrassed I felt so stupid I was just
like oh that's I'm so it's like it put
me back in high school when I would be
the first one to make the fat joke so
that like people wouldn't you know I'm
like in on the joke he he like I get it
titties like whatever so it put me in
that same space where I'm like oh so now
that's my new thing I'm trying not to
make jokes about how I look and I'm
trying not to make suicide jokes and all
these things because they are real and I
do use humor but yeah there is a certain
point where it makes people feel like oh
this is dark yeah sure it's like yeah
but everybody does it so don't beat
yourself up for it I mean [__] dude you
know I probably made 20 mistakes like
that today but it's like uh I think
being aware of it really makes a
difference to where like if you do do it
don't beat yourself up just like [__]
right I did it and they move on right
yeah that's what I would think yeah
yeah it did
I really was trying to like I was I was
like oh what should I talk about oh I'll
try to think of something funny like
yeah
I think uh you know for what it's worth
I think that Scott's points are valid I
think that uh you know
to
show up and and kind of face everything
going on and and uh be
nervous about it and and uh accountable
for it I think that that's the best you
can do and I think that that uh for what
it's worth that it went really well
thank you thank you yeah I'm definitely
gonna overthink it later and be like oh
that was I [__] up I [__] that up
but thank you and here we are once again
my wonderful street team the beautiful
people who stick around to the end of
the podcast you know there's some stuff
I want to say to you last week we had
the episode with bam and uh you know I
I don't have anything to apologize for
just want to put that out there and um
Shane Dawson I'm glad we did that too
don't feel apologetic about that either
and um man I'm still in Australia and
what a trip this has been
there's a video that we made out here
that is
wildly naughty it's I don't even know
where we can put it except of course at
stevoraw.com where it is but
man it's
been a wild trip man and I love you guys
thank you for sticking around